my mother-in-law when people give you
advice that they write they're super
adamant about telling you that they're
right pulling up sources on their phone
the thing I found about people giving
advice is that they like to give it
whether you ask for it or not don't give
it a baby a bath at night or she'll get
sick there's so much advice that we're
given constantly that I just completely
disregard because what worked for
somebody isn't gonna work for us just
listen to your mom God you'll know what
to do I am absolutely not a perfect
parent if I had to describe a perfect
parent I don't think I would be able to
do that no when we started having to
transition into formula it was a huge
emotional weight it felt like I was
failing as a mother to do the thing that
was so natural and easy at least it
appears natural and easy it's not I've
been really lucky
breastfeeding is it's just such a
special moment for us and so I'm so
grateful I had planned to breastfeed but
nothing goes according to plan we ended
up doing both formula and breast feeding
being able to feed him gave me an
opportunity to bond with him we
definitely did a little formula towards
the end your body just gets physically
tugged on like it's wearing emotionally
and physically formula breast milk
however you get to a healthy happy baby
that's what matters we were basically
told just let her sleep and wake up
whenever none of the kids slept until we
trained them sleep deprivation is the
real thing I've fallen down the stairs
twice we do mostly breast feeding at
night I just whip out baby formula
played a really big part in her bedtime
routine became the indicator that it was
time to sleep rather than my body being
the comfort
Lilly is my daughter and I know this
because she farts like a champ I know
she cried haha
you feel so helpless you lie them on
their back and you take your legs oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] when we tried the second
formula it was like other people's
opinions about what works for our family
don't really matter being a good parent
to me means to be present and to show up
I look at Natalie and I think she's
kicking butt so don't tase me as long as
we're on the same page that's all that
matters
[Music]